to this day the most embarrassing thing  that's ever happened to me in my life  is when my mom came home early from work  and found me  trying to take her bra off of my brother  i did not live that [ __ ] thing down  for a long time  listen and i'll tell you this is why i  am the way i am i'm gonna tell you what  happened that night this is who raised  me this is why i am the way i am  so that night we're at dinner right my  brother and i are sitting across from  each other and my parents are sitting  across from each other and um  my mom is this really passive-aggressive  northeastern  jew and sitting at the end of the table  and she was like  tommy my dad tommy  the funniest thing happened today  i came home early to surprise the boys  and boy did i  ever  i came home and i found joshua trying to  take my bra  off of jonathan isn't that funny  and this is why i am the way i am my dad  is at the end of the table and he cuts a  piece of meat and he goes  how'd he do  you